putin versetzt seine atomstreitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft und gleichzeitig kann
die eilmeldung rein dass man sich zu
gesprächen treffen werde mit der ukraine
jetzt auch seitens der ukraine
bestätigt wir wollen darüber sprechen
wir mit unserem reporter peter tiede
derzeit unterwegs in russland und uns
jetzt auch zugeschaltet peter eine
nachricht sie wirklich eine massive
drohung gen westen ist eine massive
bedrohung auch an uns alle ist an diesem
tag in dem wir ja die
regierungserklärung im bundestag
verfolgt haben wir verfüttern daß auch
hundert milliarden für die bundeswehr
bereit gestellt werden bekommen wir
jetzt diese nachrichten dieser
eilmeldung diese breaking news wie
bewertest du das
im kreml sitzt ein wahnsinniger das kann
man nicht mehr anders sagen also erhält
der gesamten welt nicht mehr nur der
ukraine erhält der gesamten welt die
pistole an den kopf russland besitzt
mehr als die hälfte aller atomwaffen auf
der ganzen welt
6255 hat das friedensforschungsinstitut
sipri gezählt und das ist wirklich
beängstigend wir müssen uns das einmal
vorstellen russland das größte land der
welt die atomwaffen die am dichtesten an
uns dran stehen die an deutschlandtrend
schienen stehen im alten deutschen
königsberg ihm heute große dem heutigen
russischen kaliningrad eine exklave in
polen von dort werden wir seit jahren
schon wieder bedroht wladimir putin hat
da etwa nach geheimdienstinformationen
2016 17 angefangen entgegen alten
verträgen wieder atomwaffen zu
stationieren die fliegen so bis
frankfurt/oder kurzem zwischen frankfurt
oder also deutsch polnische grenze bis
nach berlin jetzt wieder andere
aufgestellt worden und man sieht hier
also wir haben wieder den kalten krieg
den eiskalten krieges stehe im
schneesturm in russland und das ist
jetzt wieder zurück und von da an kommt
von kaliningrad bis hinten jetzt gehen
wir einmal den grob der den halben
globus herum bis zum bis nach bis zum
eismeer drüber und dann nach kamtschatka
überall stehen atomwaffen um des kaisers
mongolei die orgien denken den kaukasus
lang um am polarmeer die bis in den
bissen polarmeer einer sms ist eine
insel so groß wie die ddr eine
doppelseitige heimat um insel der russen
wladimir putin hat in den letzten jahren
nur ein einzige sache in seinen ganzen
land modernisiert das war das militär
und das war vor allem die
atomstreitkräfte da hat er geld
investiert dass dann selber ein
wirtschaftlicher zwerg ist im niedergang
ist am verboten in weiten teilen der und
außerdem petersburg und aus dass gar aus
diesen großstädten
ist das land kaputt das einzige was
nicht kaputt ist ist die atom die
atomstreit kraft und die aktivierte
jetzt die sätze in alarmbereitschaft wir
wissen nicht ob er sie einsetzt unter
normalen umständen würde wir sagen das
ist nur eine drohung aber da die mir
putin hat schon so viel wahr gemacht von
dem man geglaubt hat dass er das nicht
macht alleine die ankündigung die die
atomstreitkräfte in alarmbereitschaft zu
versetzen ist eine drohung an die ganze
welt und wladimir putin das kann man
nicht anders wollten möchte nur noch mit
peking und mit den usa verhandeln und
die ukraine scheint nur ein kleiner
schritt auf dem weg zu etwas anderem zu
sein was sollte mir putin vor ort was
uns alle nicht ausmalen wollen welche
reaktionen seitens des westens hältst du
jetzt für die richtige in dieser
brenzligen situation welche reaktion von
china hältst du für am
wahrscheinlichsten
fangen wir am besten an da gibt es nur
drei sachen härtel hatte er einfach
nicht nachgeben und china muss wladimir
putin jetzt einhalt gebieten china ist
die letzte richtige schutzmacht die er
hat früher war moskauer die schutzmacht
von anderen staaten jetzt ist ist ja
wirklich abhängig vor allem von china er
hat sich mit dem was in der ukraine
gemacht hat wir dem westen im prinzip
den rücken gekehrt hat wir alle verträge
gebrochen hat die kasse die schlussakte
von helsinki auf der fuß ist mitte der
70er jahre ein riesenerfolg ist die
verabschiedet worden die
unverletzlichkeit von grenzen die
friedliche koexistenz ein regelwerk zum
zusammenleben in europa in den müll
geworfen
die minsker verträge wo man mit der
ukraine verhandelt hat in den müll
geworfen
atomwaffensperrvertrag in den müll
geworfen alles das was unser
zusammenleben unser friedliches leben
geregelt hat hat er vernichtet und jetzt
spielt er wieder mit der bombe wie
breschnew in den 80 er und in den 70 er
jahren und wie nikita chruschtschow 1962
die großen sowjetführer die die bomberg
damals gebaut haben man mag sich im
westen noch daran erinnern der nato
doppelbeschluss von von helmut schmidt
wo er fast seine eigene partei verloren
hat und
wie aufzurüsten damals hatte man angst
vor der von den ss 20 raketen der russen
auf der anderen seite standen die
pershing und das ist zurück ich bin alt
genug ich kann mich daran noch erinnern
ich kann mich daran erinnern dass wir
damals keine angst vor klimawandel oder
irgendetwas anderem hatten sondern wir
haben in ost und west alle angst gehabt
davor dass die atombombe feld dass
irgendjemand den falschen knopf drückt
es gab ja brenzlige situation wo viel
interpretation wann wo in russland
einmal ein mutiger offizier als atom war
als als atomalarm ausgelöst worden ist
man weiß bis heute nicht genau warum hat
er gewartet und gewartet hat die klopfen
nicht gedrückt und an diese schwelle
bringt wladimir putin die welt wieder er
droht der gesamten gerät das kann man
nicht anders sagen wir mit atomwaffen
droht er sagt weil der westen harte
wirtschaftssanktionen macht versetze ich
meinen atomstreitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft der bedroht die die
welt weil das ist nicht begrenzt das ist
kein lokaler schlag das gilt nicht um
die ukraine das geht nicht mehr um
europa droht der gesamten welt das
größte land der welt mit dem größten
automarkt der welt wladimir putin ich
sag nur so der wahnsinnige man im kreml
macht einen auf richtig dicke hose und
ich weiß nicht weiter gehen will und ich
weiß auch nicht wer ihn stoppen soll
denn das ist die frage aller fragen
peter wie weit wird gene wie sehr hast
du es für wahrscheinlich dass er diese
drohung diese massive drohungen an die
welt eines teiles auch wirklich umsetzen
könnte
ich gehe jetzt mal die hoffen und die
dich auf das lade mir putin noch
irgendwo molekül an vernunft vorhanden
ist das irgendwo noch etwas herum
schwirrt das doch dass da noch ein
kleines glühwürmchen um unterwegs ist
und nach irgendetwas erhält in diesen
mann der da im kreml ist der in seinem
eigenen land zuerst aufgeräumte die
opposition mundtot gemacht hat uns warm
und tod im wortsinne ermordet außer
landes geschafft oder in gulags geworfen
der mit seinem eigenen volk abgerechnet
hat wer sich jetzt keine volle der in
kasachstan einmarschiert ist der
indianer muss dem diktator girl käufer
dieser mann der an seine eigene
sowjetunion festlegen vielleicht ist
dann noch ein molekül noch einen atom
noch irgendetwas da was in der vernunft
ist unterstellt dass mal ich hoffe dass
das mal dann handelt es sich nur um
propaganda dann handelt es sich um
propaganda vor allem nach innen wladimir
putin weiß mehr als 60 prozent seiner
russen wollen die alte sowjetunion
wieder haben sind der meinung ihr land
gehört auch die weltbühne und zwar als
weltmacht er kann das aber nicht anders
machen als mit der bombe weltmacht ist
in nur mit der atombombe wirtschaftlich
ist russland 1 werk noch mal das größte
land der erde mit dem
bruttoinlandsprodukt der
wirtschaftsleistung knapp von italien
und damit kann man nichts reißen der
lebt vom verkauf der rohstoffe verkauft
sachen die vom paar millionen vom
medialen jahren irgendwo in der erde
verschwunden sind die holt heraus es
gibt keine produkte die die welt aus
russland braucht es gibt steht
unterschreibt ist der kann nichts
anderes importiert er hat kein
wirtschaftsmodell anders als peking
peking hat das und er wird demnächst das
weiße auch bei peking am tropf hängen
daher die hoffnung dass das propaganda
ist und dass peking und die usa ihn
stoppen können um den preis dass nur mit
mir wieder reden muss das ist ein
ziemlich hoher preis schon weil mit so
jemandem redet man eigentlich nicht weil
er sich eigentlich verabschiedet in die
preisklasse von jim rakete dem
verrückten herrscher von nordkorea peter
tiede und es zugeschaltet aus russland
vielen herzlichen dank der wir wollen
weiter darüber sprechen putin fall
selbst seine atomstreitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft und hier im studio zu
gast des dr markus ferber
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher der
fdp schön dass sie hier sind ganz
ehrliche antwort macht ihnen das angst
ich glaube das macht jedem angst wir
haben den überfall putins auf die
ukraine gesehen da hat man schon am
geisteszustand gezweifelt aber jetzt die
atomwaffen in alarmbereitschaft zu
versetzen das ist ein völlig
unprovoziert schritt und da wird glaube
ich eben angst wir haben gehört von paul
ronzheimer und zugeschaltet aus kiew der
ganz klar gesagt hat die ukraine die ist
davon gar nicht so sehr überrascht wir
haben immer davor gewarnt es bleibt also
die frage wann wie naiv ich glaube die
deutsche öffentlichkeit war relativ
lange naiv war man an frieden gewöhnt
war und wenn man es nicht gewöhnt war
das andere nicht so vernünftig sind wie
man selbst die ukraine haben 1994
freiwillig ihre atomwaffen abgegeben und
russland hat im gegenzug der ukraine die
territoriale unversehrtheit garantiert
und heute sehen wir ja was die ukraine
davon hat deswegen hier gibt es nur
einen weg man muss dem regime putin mit
härte begegnet man darf nicht
provozieren aber man muss ihn mit härte
begegnen deswegen war halt auch völlig
richtig dass wir die modernisierung der
bundeswehr auf den weg bringen mit härte
begegnen gleichzeitig für putin genau
das jetzt auch ins feld und begründet
seinen schritt mit den sanktionen und
dem aggressiven zitat vorgehen nato also
diesen weg auch zu schaffen ist kein
ganz so einfacher was glauben sie wie
muss der westen reagieren wie muss vor
allem aus china reagieren ich glaube wir
haben gesehen dass der westen
unglaublich geschlossen reagiert und das
hat putin vielleicht doch überrascht
dass man jetzt so schnell zu deutlichen
wirtschaftssanktionen kommt dass auch
alle länder in europa und darüber hinaus
jetzt der ukraine solidarisch gegenüber
stehen dass sie die ukraine unterstützen
mit ausstattungen mit waffen mit
munition das was die ukraine jetzt auch
brauchen und er sieht dazu dass die
russischen streitkräfte nicht wirklich
vorankommen dass die ukraine sich
wesentlich besser verteidigen als
erwartet ich glaube er hat erwartet dass
er handstreichartig in kiew
einmarschiert und den sihlsee lenski
verhaften kann das passiert nicht das
frustriert ihn und ich denke er merkt
auch dass in seinem eigenen land der
druck wächst es ist die frage aller
fragen die auch besonders schwer zu
beantworten ist man muss so ein bisschen
in die glaskugel schauen aber was
glauben sie wie viel wahrheit steckt da
drin wie viel propaganda strikt da drin
für wie wahrscheinlich halten sie es
dass putin seine drohungen wahr machen
würde unter vernünftigen menschen würde
man immer sagen er wird diese drogen
nicht wahr machen ist nimmt keinen
nuklearen erstschlag geben denn wenn man
das sagt geht man aber davon aus dass er
auch noch bei verstand ist und da
niemand von uns ihn in den letzten
jahren gesehen hat weil er sich auch im
kreml ein ii gilt auch kaum noch soziale
kontakte hat weiß niemand wirklich ob er
noch bei verstand ist und das ist hier
das risiko und das ist natürlich auch
eine situation der schrillen bei allen
vier alarmglocken und da geht das gefühl
der angst eingangs bei uns im gespräch
natürlich besonders nach oben wir ziehen
einmal die bilanz womöglich ein irrer
man sitzt mit atomwaffen da völlig
isoliert und wirft diese drohung jetzt
der welt entgegen
eine gruselige situation es ist eine
gruselige situation
man muss natürlich jetzt sehr vorsichtig
sein wie man agiert man darf jetzt da
nicht provozieren man darf nicht
eskalieren
man muss einfach sagen bis hierher und
nicht weiter und das ist das was der
westen jetzt glaube ich sage das ist
hoffentlich das das signal auch aus dem
deutschen bundestag von heute das wird
das signal sein nächste woche von der un
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen dem punkt wo alle nationen
zusammenkommen
dass ihm dort ein klares stoppzeichen
entgegen gehalten wird und dann habe ich
die hoffnung dass ja auch noch mal
innehält und den krieg beendet und nicht
noch weiter eskaliert und auch
deutschland hat ja wirklich eine 180
grad wendung hingelegt jetzt also heute
die nachricht 100 milliarden werden in
die bundeswehr gebuttert als
sonderzahlungen und auch waffen werden
jetzt geliefert ist das genug und kam es
zu spät waffen und munition für die
ukraine ist ein anfang dort muss
sicherlich noch mehr kommen die frage
ist aber eben auch was können wir
sinnvolles beitragen panzerfäuste
stinger raketen sind jetzt ein wichtiger
beitrag anderer nationen tun ihren teil
auch dazu bei gerade munition in einem
andauernden krieg ist ist ja wichtig das
war jetzt ein sehr sehr wichtiger anfang
es kommt jetzt auch die modernisierung
der bundeswehr hinzu aus meiner sicht
mache jetzt seit fünf jahren
verteidigungspolitik für die freien
demokraten aus meiner sicht etwas zu
spät diese neue regierung fängt aber
jetzt erst an das heißt dieses
sonderprogramm ist extrem notwendig denn
unsere bundeswehr hat vieles nicht unser
gerät ist alt ist wir haben hubschrauber
die sind älter als wir beide
dementsprechend haben die auch nicht
mehr die leistungsfähigkeit wir sind
häufig gewartet werden und wir haben zum
beispiel auch selber nicht genug
munition um einen ernsthaften konflikt
zu führen wie lange wird es dauern denn
so eine nachricht an das ja auch nichts
was man vorher nicht wusste macht einem
jetzt in dieser neuen
bedrohungssituation in dieser neuen
eskalation natürlich besonders sorge das
heißt wie lange glauben sie wird es
dauern bis wir die bundeswehr auf dem
stand haben dass sie die nato wirklich
unterstützen kann und dass sie auch im
ernstfall in der lage wäre ihr land zu
verteidigen wir haben das glück dass wir
nicht allein sind mit unserem land
sondern dass wir in einem starken
bündnis it integriert sind aber das
projekt programm das wir jetzt auflegen
in der ampelkoalition wenn wir jetzt
verträge schließen niemand hat die
munition irgendwo liegen niemand hat
neue waffensysteme schwere
transporthubschrauber irgendwo rum
stehen das heißt sie müssen dann erst
produziert und gebaut werden wir müssen
auch bundeswehrsoldaten dann daran
ausbilden das heißt wenn wir jetzt
loslegen und das war heute der richtige
startschuss dann haben wir hoffentlich
in drei jahren in vier jahren eine
bundeswehr die auch die aufgabe zur
landesverteidigung bündnisverteidigung
wieder übernehmen können gut drei jahre
brauchen wir dazu also nach der sagt dr
markus ferber verteidigungspolitischer
sprecher der fdp danke für ihren besuch
bei uns im studio und wir sprechen er
weiter über diese nachricht die die
agents natürlich in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt putin versetzt seine
atomstreitkräfte in alarmbereitschaft
und das löst ich habs gerade gesagt
natürlich auch alarm in der ganzen welt
aus wie kommt diese nachricht in der
ukraine an wir schalten direkt nach kiew
peter hell der dort bei sonnenschein auf
dem dach steht und dann kommt diese
nachricht wie kommt diese nachricht
peter jetzt in der ukraine an paula das
gesagt die menschen dort haben das
gefühl wir haben es euch schon immer
gesagt
da sehen wir dass die verbindung im
moment nicht ganz stabil ist da wollen
wir natürlich weiter daran arbeiten ich
sehe peter aber ich glaube er kann ich
leider nicht hören ich versuche es noch
einmal hin anzusprechen peter helfe uns
in kiew ganz mich hören
das versuchen wir weiterhin aufzubauen
ich weiß noch einmal zusammen hier die
entwicklungen am heutigen tage putin hat
seine atomstreitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt das ist eine
massive drohungen an den westen die wir
hier im laufe dieser sendung auch weiter
analysieren wollen gleichzeitig hat auch
die ukraine bestätigt dass es gespräche
geben wird mit russland man will sich
dazu an der bulle pähler russischen
grenze treffen da also dann miteinander
hat zum ersten mal seit dem der krieg
ausgebrochen ist heute tag 4 dieses
krieges miteinander ins gespräch kommen
wir versuchen jetzt noch einmal nach
kiew zu schalten die verbindung ich sage
es ihnen gleich ist nicht ganz stabil
wir wollen trotzdem einmal bei peter
hält die reaktionen aus der ukraine
abfangen auf die tatsache dass putin
seine atomstreitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft versetzt hat peter
hell über
die ankündigung die eskalationsstufe
noch mal wesentlich aufzuziehen nochmal
eine stufe höher zu machen gleichzeitig
war aber dann kam die nachricht von den
friedensgesprächen und das hat uns
wiederum nicht überrascht denn so wie es
ihr aus der kriegszone aussieht hat
wladimir putin und seine truppen
erkennbare schwierigkeiten den zielen
vorzugeben oder nachzukommen was sie
sich vorgestellt haben sie versuchen
verzweifelt hier gegen ein gegner
anzurennen der vermeintlich kleiner ist
er aber über menschliches leistet die
ukraine und die bürger leisten den
russischen truppen den anstürmenden
russischen truppen derartig widerstand
das hatten sie selber so nicht erwartet
also mann hatte die ukrainische truppen
wesentlich schwächer erwartet und die
russischen truppen wesentlich stärker
hier hat das so ein bisschen das den
geschmack dass putin weiß er kann sich
hier in eine richtige sackgasse fahren
das heißt er steht hier zehn kilometer
vor kiew wenn wir dass man anscheinend
wenn wir uns das anschauen und er kommt
nicht voran heute auch den flughafen
wieder verloren das diesen wichtigen
brückenkopf den er überhaupt unbedingt
braucht um überhaupt weitere truppen
hier rein zu bringen und dann droht die
natürlich ihm und seinen truppen hier in
kiew eine blutige abwehrschlacht der
bürger und der ukrainischen armee das
heißt er merkt dass er hier sich
eventuell verrannt hat dazu kommt dieses
unglaubliche solidaritätsgefühl nicht
nur hier in der ukraine sondern auch in
der welt im eigenen land
europa zeigt zum ersten mal
geschlossenheit und sie zeigen stärke
und was meine rede vorgänger vorher
schon richtig gesagt haben stärke ist
das einzige was putin versteht so und
wir interpretieren das mit dieser atom
spirale mit der nächsten
eskalationsstufe so ein wenig er will
sein gesicht nicht verlieren er will auf
der einen seite vielleicht verhandeln
demnächst an der wähler russischen
grenze aber gleichzeitig und putin ist
ein schachspieler zieht er die
eskalation schraube wieder hoch damit er
nicht im eigenen land bei seinen eigenen
leuten dasteht wie der große verlierer
peter helfe uns zugeschaltet aus kiew
vielen herzlichen dank die ja die
verbindung stand entschuldigen sie war
nicht ganz stabil aber so ist es eben
wenn man in ein kriegsgebiet schaltet
wieder hell passt weiterhin gut auf dich
auf und bei uns ist jetzt björn stritzel
ist sozusagen unser ja militärexperte
hierbei bild herzlich willkommen im
studio werden diese neue nachricht die
wir heute bekommen haben eine neue stufe
jetzt in diesem krieg eine neue
eskalationsstufe und eine massive
drohung gen westen wie bewertest du die
also so wie es ja einige von meinen
vorräten auch schon richtig gesagt haben
dass man das natürlich dass es natürlich
sehr besorgniserregend ist einfach
aufgrund der lage die putin sich da
hinein manövriert hat dass man nicht
genau weiß in welchem geisteszustand
befindet er sich eigentlich noch
andererseits hat natürlich diese drohung
auch immer noch einmal zu sagen kann
erpresserisch rationalen kern dass er
natürlich noch mal klar machen möchte
ich habe ich habe dasselbe potenzial
oder zumindest an der anzahl nach sogar
mehr nukleare sprengköpfe als die usa
ich bin den führer einer weltmacht das
spielt ja auch damit hinein dass er
hauptsächlich mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten beiden über diese krise
verhandeln wollte und eben nicht mit zu
müssen nicht vorrangig mit den europäern
insofern ist es natürlich auch mehr
auch noch erstmal macht eine
machtdemonstration er hat das
tatsächlich auch schon
nach der nach der annexion der krim
damals oder während der aktion der krim
2014 zumindest ein außenminister lawrow
hatte damals auch damit gedroht dass die
dass die russischen nuklear streitkräfte
auch in alarmbereitschaft versetzt
werden können wenn wenn die ukraine
sozusagen mit einem gegen vorstoß ihr
territorium wieder zurückerobern wollen
putin hat das später dann auch noch mal
zugegeben dass man eben ja klar das ist
unsere militärdoktrin dass ein angriff
auf russisches territorium
was auch mit konventionellen waffen
erfolgen kann das dann auch einen
nuklearen gegenschlag geben kann wie
denkst du ist die richtige antwort des
westens wie es die richtige antwort der
westlichen welt jetzt auf diese drohung
wir ein bisschen damit überfragt so als
politikberater aber ich glaube dass das
das natürlich nur stärke und
entschlossenheit
da tatsächlich dass das sind mit dem wie
man wie man putin da die man putin da
begegnen kann ohne dass man da jetzt
gleich auch in
ja sagen das haben wir einen so eine
angst vor allem im kalten krieg vor vor
tatsächlich einer nuklearen nuklearen
auseinandersetzung sich befindet ich
glaube die die vorzeichen sind schon
noch etwas anders als etwa bei der
kubakrise oder dergleichen ich will gar
nicht das verharmlosen und klein reden
weil wir eben nicht wissen in welchem
geisteszustand wladimir putin sich
befindet und wie sehr sie vielleicht
auch
in seinem eigenen machtapparat unter
druck geraten ist wenn man sich heute
angeschaut hat sein als er den befehl
gegeben hat sozusagen in dieser video
ansprache an sein verteidigungsminister
an
also das einschalten der
generalstabschef gerasimov die schauten
beide etwas griesgrämig drein und
wandert also wenn man ein bisschen
psychologie betreiben will also aus
ihren gesichtern abzulesen wirkt nicht
besonders glücklich über diesen über
diesen befehl
insofern glaube ich dass der westen gut
daran tut weiter die ukraine zu
unterstützen
und nicht in einer rhetorik zu verfallen
oder nicht sich darauf einzulassen auf
diese nuklearen auf diesen nuklearen
schreckensszenarien stritzel und sechs
werte ich hier bei bild vielen
herzlichen dank für deinen besuch seiner
analyse hier im studio